what's up everyone we have the Rog Phone
7 Ultimate that has finally landed it
comes with its own cooling fan the air
active 7 cooler and it has Armory crate
and Game Genie it has some of the best
thermal management designs on the market
and we are going to be running this
through our gaming Gauntlet the engine
impact pubg mobile Call of Duty mobile
and Diablo Immortal performance wise the
Rog Phone 7 that we are using has a
Snapdragon in Gen 2 and a journal 740
for GPU 16 gigs of RAM 512 gigs of
storage and everything plays out on 865
Hertz 6.78 inch display with a 6 000
million power battery also quick thing
to note we won't be using the air active
cooler 7 but let me run through how it
works there are four additional Triggers
on the back that you can map out with
Game Genie the coolest thing about the
ultimate version of The Phone 7 is that
it has this interactive portal
essentially it is a hatch that only
opens up when you attach the cooler to
it and allows for the cool air to enter
the phone but of course you won't be
attaching the air active cooler 7 all
the time so we'll be testing the phone
without it to see how far the game Cool
7 cooling system can take the phone
before we run the test let's do a
baseline of the temperatures on the
front and back of the phone
So currently we are at 27.5 on the top
and 28 the front it's it's pretty cool
honestly and now for the back
27 27.9 28 28.5 all right looks like we
are in the green to start this gaming
test we are currently at 100 and let's
get into our first game we will be
setting up the air triggers as we go
along so before that let's enter Omni
create and enable X movement so on the
console page of army recruit you can see
that it is tracking the CPU and GPU
temperatures as well as the current RAM
usage and storage space that the phone
has X mode is already enabled as you can
see it does bump up the refresh rate but
the funny thing is that even though the
screen is set for 165 Hertz inexual it
will cap the frame rate to 144 Hertz as
you can see down here all right so now
that we're in game let's just access
Game Genie real quick to see where we've
mapped out all Air triggers
you can pull the top right here this top
right corner or the top left corner to
open up Game Genie and as you can see
let's just turn on real-time info so we
can see everything that's going on
and let's see etragus So currently I
have the right eye trigger on the attack
button and the left eye Trigon Sprint
that's how I do things and what I
mentioned earlier about using the air
active coolest triggers you can enable
it through the
cooler buttons down here so so long as
you have the air active pool attached
you can map out about this but since we
don't obviously you know it won't be
enabled but you can enable both the
cooler buttons and ultrasonic buttons or
the air triggers at the same time
there's also motion control here which
we won't be using so that's a nice touch
if you're into that currently our FPS is
at 61 we have 34 degrees Celsius on the
phone right now 99 battery GPU usage at
82 oh it went down it went up again
I don't even see that but yeah you can
and CPU usage is at 40 so with that
let's just check our game settings real
quick
set things and Graphics we are on the
highs for everything FPS still kept the
60 down here motion Blitz on high blooms
on everything is on to the max so
this is what we have so let's see how
the models look like
this display is really good looking as
you can see all of the little details
coming off my little companion down here
and even all the little brooches and
buttons on her outfit all right let's
move on to Performance it is a very good
looking game on a very good looking
phone and honestly they both complement
each other so well all right so let's
just run through monster there aren't
any huge family drops at the most We're
Going Down by a single frame but that's
pretty much nothing and it's very smooth
just look at that it looks and feels
damn good so far just to show you the
sensitivity of the air triggers
okay pull up all the combos you want
and on the left side
so they are Uber responsive let's see
how the phone also handles character
swapping
all right all right
pretty smooth
all right so let's see how the phone
handles you know draw distances and
everything so let's just go somewhere
else
somewhere hilly or mountainy
and yeah fast traveling is really quick
it's almost instantaneous and as you can
see
this looks beautiful
wow
especially at night I kind of wish was a
day though but
this looks really good
let's keep moving
and you know it's the phone is handling
it pretty damn well and I gotta say the
audio is really doing it for me the Rog
Phone 7 Ultimate has subwoofers built in
Seoul this is honestly one of the best
audio experiences you can get other
Android phones on the market right now
so with that you know we can see that
the phone handles jaw distances and I
mean Genji looks beautiful on this
display let's get into some fighting
there we go
[Music]
together them all up
obviously using air triggers does
require some getting used to because as
you can see I'm still using the buttons
on screen it's only seeing you but the
muscle memory so
combat is pretty smooth so for I would
see any huge major framing drops it's
very smooth actually
[Music]
all right let's just do that bring our
Jean again
[Music]
foreign
all right and we are done with that
combat is pretty damn smooth but let's
see how it handles itself with these
spiral a bits
okay and so far we've been playing for
about a good 15 minutes
so let's see how the temperatures are on
the front really quickly 37ish
doing okay because honestly I haven't
really noticed the temperature
difference whatsoever
right in the back
35.6 it's doing a lot better than the
front honestly and 38 is on the top so
we're doing pretty well so far let's try
out these spiral bits
all right again let's go
[Music]
no FPS shop whatsoever the sound is
great
let's destroy the chill quick but also I
need to take care of the Arches on the
never mind
[Music]
but you know brush off
well done
push you off very nice no FPS job still
wow this phone is really doing damn well
and honestly it's still comfortable in
hand I haven't noticed any sort of like
huge temperature spikes or anything
it's over hot at all
[Music]
right so we're getting out of the way
honestly this has been one of the best
experiences I've had with any Android
phone so far
and man it just keeps getting better
every year with the Rog Fallen series so
let's just check for temperatures
internally we get 39 degrees Celsius and
let's just check it out with our
temperature gun
the surface is about 36.9
37ish so it's still doing pretty damn
well it's very cool okay it's a bit warm
but it's not uncomfortable and honestly
as you're playing you don't really
notice it so it's not steering hot or
anything
let's check the back
33-ish yeah the cool system yeah the
stove management is amazing as always
and honestly I think it has improved
quite a bit from the previous iteration
of this phone so with that Kenshin is
done let's move on to the next game pubg
mobile
all right so with pubg mobile we are
currently at 90 battery we are a good 20
minutes into the gaming session with 20
minutes being spent on kitchen impact so
currently we're still at 39 degrees
Celsius and we are running hot off the
heels from games in their back so let's
just check temperatures real quick
still at about 35-ish 36 percent
37ish on here
and at the back
we are at 35
is 36 ish yeah it has gone up a little
bit not too much but honestly pubg isn't
as graphically intensive as kimchi
impact so I'll expect to see the phone
cooling down a lot more so uh Ultra HD
we are in Ultra frame rate and the
aliasing is on up two times and yeah
that's pretty much it that's okay that
and let's just restart the game before
we get into a match
all right we're getting about 40 FPS
it is currently 37 degrees Celsius
inside the phone then you can just
exited okay great that is fine we're
gonna be running doubles or Duos
actually UI is pretty good I mean the
screen is pretty large so so long as you
you know customize your buttons property
everything should be fine so let's just
wait this out until we get to dropping
the C-130 is looking as good as always
you know the sun is reflecting off very
nicely rendering so far on the map is
looking pretty good let's jump together
and let's see where they want to go I'm
just reboot marker real quick
but yeah oh okay here we go so so far no
huge FPS drops we're still hugging
between 40 FPS 39 FPS
there's a much stuttering so
you know it's looking promising so far I
mean it did handle again chin pretty
well so let's see what we're gonna drop
off but before that you know screen
responds is pretty great these so are
the air triggers right here
and let's wait it out oh we're going to
Gekko
and yeah I'm hoping there isn't much of
an enemy presence on here hopefully no
one else drops with us and I don't think
okay oh we got a squad in front of us a
score of one it appears
you could be really cracked but we
wouldn't know yet all right I'm just
going in for that house and let's get to
looting
all right oh we've got a us here
beautiful
all right nope okay
got it for Moss 5.56 rounds
everything's doing pretty great
all right as you can see it's very
responsive when we ads
like oh okay we got one down one down
one down
there we go two down
where is it where is you at oh there you
are okay never mind my guy got him oh
okay I see the smoke I see the guy
there we go horse Squad is down
beautiful so for the firefight you can
see that air triggers make you Superior
all these triggers in general make you
Superior to all other players on the
server oh what's happening
so imagine if you use the air active
cooler and it's four other triggers it
will be amazing
let's get this licks
one down where is the guy at
okay somewhere on that side oh do I see
them
all right I got one guy
all right
all right two guys on
grenade that's not mine
five five we are doing pretty well so
far
all right you down
those huge family jobs whatsoever we're
doing very well right now
I think I'd say we're good halfway
through a match let's go 10 15 minutes
really on the how is it I can't remember
how many circles already but I think
about the third or second Circle right
now
we are currently 85 battery I believe
the temperature has dropped quite a bit
let's just check out this guy's box real
quick the one I killed early on
Fire Grenade all right I'll get it
moldov as well get that Molly oh no I
think I took it but that one yeah
so let's just check out
uh temperatures real quick hopefully no
one fights us right now check
temperatures real quick
all right 35 it has gone down quite a
bit actually
all right okay let's check the back
early we are at 33 degrees 34 yeah it
has gone down quite significantly the
thermal Management on this oh God damn
it the thermal Management on this phone
is insane so far nothing much is going
on we have oh we got guys on this side
somewhere
okay I see him
you guys going
they got rid
oh I see him
walk down
that was a lucky one
this guy let's go let's go
come out
yeah it sounds very close
oh we won nice okay
honestly it feels really good to be
playing with the rg-417 with all the eye
triggers and anything if we use the
interactive cooler man this would just
up the game experience even more so with
that let's just move on to the next game
let's do final temperature checks first
though
uh 35-ish 34 on the front it has gone on
quite significantly as the game has
progressed from genshin let's just check
the back I need to figure this out
that's that's almost ice cool
it's like the phone's hardly working I
mean it is but damn door Management on
another level RG
all right
so with that let's move on to the next
game
Call of Duty mobile right before we move
on to Call of Duty this channel is
supported by Brands to help us improve
our content and keep us going so stay
around for the sponsored message meet
the Cyber 15 gaming laptop from MSI
check out this translucent material
design that not only looks good but
feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
intercore i7 HD series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its nahimic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com with that let's do all
the Call of Duty but before that
temperature checks we are hard of the
heels of pubg and it has gone down
significantly it was like 35 34 on the
front early on it that was what 32. that
is that is insane all right check the
back 31 wow it is going to quite a lot
okay okay okay okay okay okay
all right let's move on to Call of Duty
now that we are in the landing page you
know the major looks really damn good
and let's just check out settings real
quick
audio and Graphics we are on very high
Max frame rate Ultra frame from
multiplayer but because you know we're
not really pushing the phone you only
sets the medium there's something you
can't go higher than that you don't have
to go higher but the graphic quality you
gotta push it up to Max only so let's go
to very high graphic quality and for the
multiplayer that feels on
the time Shadow is ragged all on Bloom
is on because why not anti-educing and I
believe we are good to go as you can see
you know the landing page frame rate was
about 30-ish degrees but I think it
should go up a lot higher when we get
into the game
60 FPS on the front 51 kind of dropped a
bit but you know what it's looking
pretty dang good candle how it looks wow
okay it looks really nice
it's exactly like the one in Modern
Warfare
as you can see the effects of the camera
on the gun looks really good and let's
see the scope real quick oh the scope
works really well oh look at how the Sun
reflects off the buttons this looks
really good oh my Lord all right let's
go
oh so good
yeah add sugar is basically just make it
feel like you're cheating let's just get
on the point real quick
hardpoint is ours hop on right now I
don't see anyone coming where is the
enemy team oh there you go
you're on the hunt to kill up
load oh I think it was someone there
oh there you go
oh this these triggers man
all right get some quick scoping in
well there we go oh we got a nuke what
okay okay okay okay
that should be the game right oh never
mind no scope I keep forgetting that
nukes don't end the game and called
mobile but you should be doing pretty
damn well I mean anything is pretty much
on it never mind it
foreign
did it swim up
this is a very smooth game also we're
currently at 77 from playing a full
match of pubg mobile and games for like
what 20 minutes so honestly this one is
doing very well with how it manages one
thing thermal so obviously it's battery
consumption even on xmod which is it's
boosted mode
oh man okay I didn't get MVP slot in
this I mean he did get nuke so that's
fine but other than that playing
bottling that thing called Mobile on
this phone is a dream the air triggers
really do help out quite a bit when it
comes to you know managing recoil and
whatnot
so we're and the thing is it never
dropped FPS didn't drop at the most what
like 59 FPS but it's been at the
constant 60 FPS for the longest time
haven't seen any drastic FPS drops so
it's it's handling itself more than well
it's it's the rg410 ultimate and this is
really the Autumn experience auditory
thermal wise everything this is great
all right so let's just do a final
temperature checks and move on to Diablo
immortal
all right so the front 33 degrees 34 I
think it increased by what a single
degree ish on the front and for the back
we are currently at 26.5 33 it's still
very cool to the touch
not uncomfortable it's very comfortable
in fact so let's just move on to the
next game Diablo immortal all right so
before Diablo Immortal let's just do a
quick temperature check
we are hot on the heels from Call of
Duty mobile it's still like 34ish
degrees so you know what it will go down
eventually
22 32 still 33 at the back it's all
right it's all good it's literally
nothing honestly compared to other
phones I reviewed so far this is
swimming pool this takes a cake for
thermal management right Diablo immortal
60 FPS for his frame rate resolution is
on high because Ultra for some reason
it's not supported on this device but it
definitely should be all right let's
wait for updates everything's on very
very high everything is turned on and
yeah we are doing pretty damn well
okay let's see if I need to clear
anything in my stash yeah okay I do need
to visit the statue quick so let's just
have a quick walk through this much but
as you can see the environment is
beautiful the Shadows coming off really
nicely
off the Sun and whatnot imagine over
here let's just enter the Elder Rift
all right clean there except yes all
right let's make it challenging
enter
should be bright enough for y'all to see
there's going to be a lot of effects
going on because I am playing a
necromancer
all right okay
okay uh skeletal Mitch Max yes let's do
that
all right it is very dark
but you know what
it's okay
let's get pushing through wow this
thing's really dark right now we just
bumped it up
watching the modify it makes it very
dark but as you can see this thing is
doing very very well
60 FPS not a dent in that FPS
but you know the thing is with all of
this going on with all these effects and
all my units out there
it's full I mean if this one could
handle again you can handle it it
can handle anything
two or more
and there you go
and oh my God there is so many of them
she was all these NPCs in line oh yeah
okay I am actually losing out right now
wow oh okay no wonder
it's a legendary enemy all right cool
okay we got the
shot in here I don't know who it is and
of course it's true
the Summoner
all right it's just put everything you
have all teeth I follow real quick and I
think we'll be able to kill him
relatively fast it's powerful is
dropping down tremendously
hey yep okay we're done
with all the NPCs or all the enemies and
all of my own minions this one can
handle it pretty damn well and honestly
let's just do a quick temperature check
real quick uh it is at 3 4 right now 35
ish I think it increased by like one or
two degrees let's check the bag now and
4 yep it's insane all right even with
this pure AMOLED display down here
it's not it's not steering hard it's
still very comfortable to play with so
with that all the way let's just do some
exploration let's go to my favorite
place the actual cemetery and see what's
up over there
please do a little bit of exploration
here and there and just you know just
have a good time and so far you know
obviously my guys are just going to be
cooking through everything and everyone
like a heart attack but yes I'll be
using that analogy again but oh this
feels so good look at that
it's destroying everything in my path
remember with all the effects and
everything going on it is handling this
screen like a chat but it's under all
the games like a champ actually
especially against you so I expect
nothing less from this one oh man
honestly I I think you guys have seen
that I've seen enough I know I know for
sure that the rz-47 is to create for the
game on so
I think we can end it off right here
we're at 60 FPS about 37 degrees Celsius
right now and
yeah let's just end this
so yeah that's it for Diablo Immortal
let's do a quick temperature check the
final one in the front is about 34
degrees ish 35. still the same but you
know it's not even hot at all let's
check the back
33 years 34 35
6 so she's doing pretty well all right
so with that let's just move on to our
final conclusions the rog-417 ultimate
lives up to the ultimate in its name it
really is one of the best if not the
best gaming experiences you can get on
the market with its amazing gamecool 7
cooling system that kept the phone at
comfortable temperatures even without
the Aero active cooler 7 attached and
not to mention it's amazing speakers the
phone is well optimized for long periods
of gaming we went through all four games
over the span of about an hour and a
half and it only took less than 30
percent of its total battery so if
you're planning to play on your commute
to work on the highest settings you're
going to be in for a treat the Rog form
series really does get better every year
and I can't wait the game on whatever
phone we have next if you have any
questions about the rot Phone 7 Ultimate
leave them in the comment section below
and I'll do my best to get to them keep
up to date with us by following us on
all of our socials for the latest news
that we put out and if you like this
video consider maybe hitting the like
button and subscribing to us if goes a
long way and if you want to see more
videos from us check this out
foreign